we found it and went there and um a lot
of the snow scenes that actually didn't
show how cold it was how cold was it
cold so um so a lot of those snow scenes
weren't they weren't supposed to happen
it snowed one day and then Teicher I'm
cycleway TT the director was like okay
well do the snow so he yeah he's sort of
adept the scenes to the snow he had
actually been praying for the snow
secretly hoping it was going to happen
but it wasn't anything on our call sheet
so it turned up when we had to do a
completely different thing but that's
what Tigers so good it didn't it didn't
it also rain and I mean you had you
almost didn't make schedule because of
how difficult the weather was yeah I
mean um
we are we shot the film in 25 days which
was a really short amount of time and we
were we were traveling at least an hour
out from the kind of main base each day
to get into the wilderness and Julian
had we were in the winter so I think he
only like nine and a half daylight hours
each day so we only had really eight
hours of data shoot so it was quite
surprising we everyone told us we
couldn't do it and we and we just sort
of took the attitude that it was sort of
went back in time we were channeling the
80s and the 70s and just thought we'll
just go for it and and on the last
couple of days when we were filming and
we were we were going to make the
schedule I sort of almost couldn't talk
and I couldn't believe it that we've
done it well I was reading somewhere it
was sort of like the New Zealand
military helped you or what was that um
yeah they helped us on one day they have
like these hot packs so I'm because we
were so far out we couldn't get like
some of the you know hot foods and a
whole lot of trucks they bought all of
this hot food and and they really helped
us you know as you saw things in the
trucks and everything and the tents and
stuff and so we filmed that so we were
about a week we filmed the car chase the
car chase for about a week oh yeah yeah
so um they really did help us over the
radios we'd hear em like that was that
it was an hour
training ground and over the radios with
the education we've found a bomb we've
found a bomb can you be can someone from
the Army come over please one of the
drivers one of the cars drivers they
would they were told like if you see in
the middle don't touch it and she just
had lunch and she was walking away from
the tent and she almost step on like
this grenade and there was like a
grenade just sitting there on the ground
none of them none of them were alive but
we were told even like our shadows could
set them off so to be very careful and
you had worked with taiko before in the
commercial or yes so I worked on a
commercial with them
I think 2012 so it was about 19 and um I
was cool don't don't don't take drugs
and drive and that went pretty I'm
pretty famous over in New Zealand and
Australian that went pretty viral and I
wanna award and an award and stuff like
that so I'm I worked with him that was
the first time you met me and he said in
a few kione's he's been saying that he
wanted to work with me but he didn't
know what project to work beyond so he
said when this came up he was like so I
didn't have the audition and he gave me
the part which was really cool you
didn't have to audition you know that he
knew this would be the key you know that
you would be the perfect Ricky but
didn't he originally write the script
about 11 years ago sort of like a writer
for hire and then it just didn't go
anywhere with another director or a
producer yeah so 10 years ago before
tiger had directed boy an eagle versus
shark and what we're doing the shadows
he was asked to write this the script by
a producer and then a couple of years
ago they hadn't been created and he
thought oh that was a great story but I
hadn't you know it's not actually come
about so he picked up the rights again
and he I think he completely rewrote the
story from ten years earlier I think he
thought he'd written as I kind of like
not a probably a comedy it was more
about being in a more about being an
outsider more of maybe an angry film and
and he'd obviously made three films
since then and really had sort of loved
comedy and so the he was able to kind of
lighten the script up and when I came on
board in 2014 he'd been working on the
script already and it was just it was
amazing script like the script the film
that you see here is not that different
from the script that he wrote like it
wasn't a film that you had to discover
the story in the year that was actually
a beautiful script from the start so it
was great well you know now it's the
perfect film to show on Father's Day
because here are these two outsiders who
you know basis weekly kind of father and
son as we see through the film and it
you know it's a kind of you know a
lovely story because you you know you
had no mother and and you know he's
having had a rough life you know but
even though he was married you know it
you know there he finally got a chance
at the end you guys were basically you
know father and father and son yeah so
I'm for about a week before we actually
started shooting um we done rehearsals
off the other cast so like the past to
play Paulo and um whatever Kitely who
played Andy the cop and all of these um
all of the different casts and sort of
getting that bond between Ricky Baker
and heck I'm so trying to get so you
know going through a lot of the toughest
scenes where I'm sad or and I'm happy so
those scenes that really see that
they're connecting yeah so really I'm
really really getting that connection
and really getting that bonding between
two characters hat was he cast in the
film because you know usually even if
he's in an action of enter aventure he's
her Bane and sophisticated and you get
you know he gets to be he seems to be
enjoying himself
scruffed up the decision to kind of take
somebody like Sam and turn him into this
into hack yeah I think um Tyco you know
Sam is obviously one of the most famous
actors in New Zealand so he's always and
he's the right age so it was quite there
was an easy connection for Tiger to make
but obviously he hasn't played a role
like this before or for a long time or
worked and comedy for a while so there
but if you look back at Sam's earlier
work you can see that he has actually
done comedy before and so we could Tiger
could see there we could see that and
has work and I think it was good that we
like the idea of being able to reinvent
his look and the feel and I think it's
great when we were on the shoot Sam
didn't want to have any photographs
outside his character
with the beard see it and had the beer
before because we want to get him like
at home with Sam Neill
but then subsequently he's rocking the
beard all the time now so oh really
yeah he's into the theater as a director
I mean you know you worked with Sam and
you did the rehearsal but just how does
he talk with you does he like give you
suggestions does he let you try a scene
the way you want to do it how does that
work it's a really great working with
Tiger um he really knows how to work
with kids you know really knows how you
know to you know he suggested I he
suggests you know what to do but he
always lets you a lot of the scenes that
Sam done you know he added his own twist
to work and then you know Sam would um
so most of the scenes in Sam put his own
twist or not he just cut him out of the
film really know he really knew how to
work with me and really you had a you
know not feel like I was working but
feel like I was having fun and sort of
getting me into the character and just
being like like just getting me active
and saw that and just you know I'm you
know four different scenes he was really
help me you like so like he was telling
me what like think about something
really sad that happened and put it into
the character and like because you know
and he reminded me and my mum and like
cuz I don't normally swear that much but
Ricky Baker and stuff he does a lot of
bad things and he was reminding me and
my mom were like you know you're not
that character but you don't awesome
drop it great character so he really
helped me um yeah he really helped me
get into the character but also Tigers I
mean very light on seeds I mean as a
person he's also a performer as well and
a comedian and so it really is like it's
really funny yeah so I think there's a
the Saints on Cedars that you're having
fun I think for everyone really even
though you're in difficult situations
think most of the time when I tuned up
to see what was going on with these guys
they were laughing uh yeah joking and
laughing and riffing different ideas
he's very open to I could to because
these comes from also a stand-up and a
you know live theater background as well
he's really relaxed about taking what's
in the room or where they are and
actually making the best out of it and
not at all precious of holding on to one
um the scene where psycho Sam and the
government of the air and he opens up
the trapdoor mm-hmm that was actually my
idea applause but um we were actually in
like a like a pool at the hotel and
that's normally where me and Sam and the
rest of the cast will go over the lines
and then Teicher was thinking of this
idea for one of the scenes and I was
like we were thinking I'm like why don't
they do a trapdoor and it hasn't been
done yet and then boom I go to the film
and yes I'll take like 0.5 but yeah yeah
he is really open to the actors ideas
and put their own twist on the scene was
it fun also just kind of play someone so
totally different I mean you know you
have a family and you go to school and
you're playing you know Ricky you know
has was a you know bad a guess is we
were you know in the movie was that at
first kind of difficult to get into his
mindset or was thanks to taiga and the
script and you know doing rehearsals did
it that make it easier for you to become
Ricky yeah definitely at the style of
the shoot it was really difficult for me
to get into the character and you know
sort of sit and like just see the one to
the character because you know um I'm
not I wasn't used to doing the stuff
that Ricky Baker does and I'm you know
mom and Teicher reminding me that you
know it's not me so you know it's um
just pretending to be someone else so
you know it was difficult at first but
Rachel House who plays Paula oh you know
social welfare I don't
um she she was actually my dialogue
coach and she without her I probably
wouldn't have been able to remember the
script or anything cuz you really helped
me you know um see the one to the cacti
learn the lines know what the lines mean
and how to say them and what pace to say
them so every night we would go over the
next scenes we're doing the next day so
she really helped me but it was
difficult at first but but like by the
last week it was really easy to like
just snap into the character do the
scene and then snap back to myself which
was really awesome thank you so much for
talking with me and thank you so much
for thank you for coming today